[Music]
robert dubois
is in prison for putting superman in the
icu with a kryptonite bullet
you're joining your suicide squad we'll
see
my court date is coming up and miss
waller said maybe you could help me out
you're threatening my door everyone
stand down
stand down
[Music]
i won't take such extreme measures this
mission went more important than you
could possibly imagine
are you in or out good
let's meet your team it's okay i'm not
okay each member has chosen for his or
her own completely unique set of
abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late i had to go
number two good to know
is this thing a a dog what kind of dog
do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound oh my god is it a
werewolf yo they saw me there's no real
one
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel
he's harmless i mean he's not harmless
he's killed 27 children but
you know
your mission is to destroy every trace
of something known only
as project starfish any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no no
all right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
stay off the comp
[Music]
foreign